our good buddy from the athletic Frank
Isola here on the program how you doing
Frank the great Rich Eisen the great
Frank Isola I'm doing better for talking
to you sir I don't even know where to
start with this does the NBA is the NBA
happy with what happened last night with
it being so completely off the wall and
it's a maybe a firing a shot across the
bow of any tank intended teams or the
teams that need the biggest help don't
really get it Frank where do they stand
on this subject right well I don't think
they never admit it but I think of Sian
Williamson ended up in New York or LA
there could be some smiling in the
league office but I think for them what
they wanted to do with the revised
format to try to prevent teams from
tanking even though I still think teams
will do it was pretty unpredictable I
mean you had a team at a 60% chance
jumping all the way to the top spot I
mean the Lakers went from having the 11
spots being fourth the Knicks went from
being one to being three and then you
look at what happened to the Suns and
obviously the Cleveland Cavaliers I felt
a little bit bad for the Atlanta Hawks
the Atlanta Hawks tried to do everything
the right way this year though they
didn't have the most talented roster
there but they came out and played hard
guys like Trey young John Collins
you know Lloyd pierced a head coach did
a very good job too bad that they fell
all the way to eight because they were
like the one team that wasn't very good
that was trying to win for most of the
season and actually did things the right
way but it didn't pay off with him last
night well I mean in previous years a
team with a 6% chance was ranked sixth
in the in the draft order this time
around a team of the six percent chance
ranked seventh through ninth and the six
percent chance in the previous lottery
days were 19 percent off from winning
the entire shooting match in the lottery
last night six percent was just nine
percent off so yeah it's leveled the
playing field but is that the right way
to do a draft Frank III I think the way
the league you know especially after
what happened in Philadelphia where they
were you know clearly tanking for all
those years I don't think the league
wants that I think a lot of fans that go
to these games late late in the season
and the big-name players aren't playing
I think that turns off
a lot of people I don't ever think
there's going to be a perfect way to do
it but again if you're a fan of the
Knicks the Cleveland Cavaliers and the
Phoenix Suns are obviously bummed that
you lost the ton of games especially in
the case of the New York Knicks you won
17 at 65 and in other years you would
had a 25% chance against another pick
and you think to yourself you know what
this is year to have been in one thing
because it's going to be cyan Williamson
I get all of that but you can't say that
it wasn't pretty exciting less and
especially I mean how many times have we
seen when they do the draft and you know
they're gonna take the commercial break
before they go to the top it used to be
the top three right now it's the top
four and you had you know the Knicks
were still alive the Lakers were in it
you know who defied the odds same thing
with New Orleans and Memphis so during
that commercial break
I started thinking I'm bad at math
that's why I had to get into this
business I'm thinking myself well hang
on the next must of odd because going
into it they had higher odds and the
three remaining teams but I was wrong
about that in fact rich how about this
you know they draw first and it was New
Orleans Memphis won the second pick and
then when they do the drawing to the
third pick Memphis won again so I'll
just have to redraw and then that turned
out to be the Knicks and then the Lakers
were fort so the Memphis came up three
times I mean two times they won second
pick in the third pick but you don't get
both there well I mean in terms of also
you know in that commercial break I just
flipped on Twitter or was tweeting out
some stuff myself and I saw you Frank
from a few minutes before saying that
you had somebody that was able to
communicate from out of the hermetically
sealed what was the what was the phrase
that that no no you use transmit but
Howard Becca was on in the first hour
call what do you call it the room the
the the sequestered room the sequestered
space yeah
has anyone from the NBA called you to
see who ordered the Code Red Frank and
got that information out I you know it's
funny to say that I did get a call from
somebody from the legal she was laughing
as they as I picked up the phone they
said you son of a gun I know exactly
what you were doing I was in that room
the year that Minnesota won the number
were picking karl-anthony towns that's
when the nextel but the end up getting
prisons and when you go in there you
know you're obviously handing over your
phone and you put it in an envelope and
you know this basically guys with
baseball bats and
you know get your phone right when I
said transmit I thought people would
understand kind of the joke I was
surprised at how many people thought I
was being serious it was you know a lot
of times sarcasm doesn't always project
via Twitter but I thought if I used the
word transmit you know what I should
have said I should have said smoke
signals but I still think people to
believe me if I'd written that somebody
sent out a smoke signal and I know who
was the number one pick but you were
accurate on it being a wild finish that
that that people would be talking about
I mean pelicans won Memphis - are you
saying you didn't nobody did tell you
this sort of in for me I know nobody
knew but I did I will say this I've been
saying for a long time there was a cruel
part of me that was hoping that the
Lakers would get it not that they
deserved the tech I always thought it'd
be so much screaming going on if the
Lakers got the number one pick and end
up with LeBron and then during that
break I had after I tweeted out the part
about someone had transmitted me the
results I tweeted that the Lakers should
have had Lavar ball
on the day I represent the team and then
of course the Lakers we knew that
they're in the top four so a lot of
people were convinced that it was the
Lakers who had won I I had no idea I'll
be honest with you if you told me during
the commercial break I would have
thought that the Knicks were gonna win
again because I'm very bad at math
that's why I'm in this business
Frank Isola the athletic here on the
Rich Eisen show which team in the top
four do you think is most likely to wind
up trading the pick that's a very that's
a very good question obviously probably
the Lakers
I think the Lakers have a chance to get
Anthony Davis if David Griffin wants to
do that I know being in the same
conference he might not be that crazy
but they do have more established
players than the other teams do and you
know Kyle Kuzma Alonzo ball now you have
the fourth overall pick I would say the
Lakers at this point the next ten still
get a good pick with it it's all gonna
depend on who goes second if John Moran
goes second and I think they're gonna
get lucky they'll get RJ berry if RJ
Barrett goes second which could happen
John Moran that's a little bit different
he was pretty slight he's got a long way
to go I know a lot of people talk about
how dynamic he is but he's gonna have to
get a lot bigger and stronger I don't
think there's any question so you know
obviously the the idea going into last
night for the Knicks was they get the
number
overall pick and they then try and trade
for Davis and maybe get Durant showing
up to use the other max contract that
they opened up because they dealt
porzingis out of the blue to Dallas
what now what's the plan now do you
think for the next I still think it's
Kevin Durant but let me ask you this do
you think a bad one the number one pick
do you think they're trading Zion one I
just think all these teams in the league
this guy has been so hyped so talked
about really one of the most talked
about players we've seen in the last 20
years probably 30 years come into League
everyone service college games I find it
hard to believe that fans of teams the
media and whatever market it would be
and what about the business side of all
these basketball organizations I think
there's so much pressure on the team not
to trade I know we're talking about
Anthony Davis but you're also talking
about a guy that's only been out of the
first round once in his career he's had
a history of injury problems I
understand the appeal of it I just doubt
that I still don't believe that the
Knicks would have done it I think it
would have held on designer' Williams
and it still tried to make a run at
Kevin Durant and Kyrie Irving I think
that's still in play but you are asking
two players though Kevin Durant is on a
great team great roster great teammates
you're asking him to come to a 17 and 65
team and Kyrie Irving and we know that
nobody gets along up there in Boston but
that doesn't you know neglect the fact
that they have great talent on that team
and he'd be coming to a team that
doesn't have similar talent now Kyrie
and Kevin Durant combined are gonna make
you a lot better is it enough in Eastern
Conference well that will be a wolf that
remains to be seen and so do you think
teams are gonna tank less next year
after last night no no I think they'll
make you know what 40% is still better
than 6% and I'll take my check cuz you
know what's gonna happen next year rich
and it's gonna drive the Knick fans not
what's not Tina finishes with the worst
record is gonna end up with the number
one overall text you can see this one
coming from a mile away and Knick fans
are going to be kicking stones are going
to be so upset about it and I it's just
unlucky the year that they decide to
revise the format that's here you have
the worst record that's the other Diane
Williamson is available and it all comes
down to bouncing balls I mean that it
can't be upset they had nothing to do
with it it's it's luck Kawhi Leonard
shot at the end of Game seven the ball
bouncer right away last night it was
that way for David Griffin Hawaii you
know I had spoken to him the night
before the draft really quickly because
I had done some radio stuff with him for
serious and he was convinced that they
were gonna win he was like so
matter-of-fact the baby I'll talk to
Marcus whirlwind leave a 6% chance
in fact I'm almost overconfident with a
six percent well I was hoping it'd be 2%
I know he's won at 4 times now the first
overlooked trick so that's why he's so
damn confident I he's these like the
lottery whisperer he should play
Powerball a hundred percent anyone so
bad he's just gonna worry I'm pretty
confident I went all the time well I
think what has to happen if the Knicks
are in the draft lottery again is just
Dolan's man Kevin who kicks people out
for a living and then or Dola man
Dolan's man Kevin who whose people who
supposedly are just ambushing Dolan and
need to be held for Kevin he just needs
to freeze the ping-pong balls better
Frank he just did I don't think he did
his job quite frankly we are G Barrett
might not be a very bad consolation
prize at all obviously help we'll see
how it goes
let's take let's thoughts let's take
this - next week - I'd love to have you
back on before the finals Frank thank
you guys Frank I so loved the athletic
at the Frank I saw four more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app